hey what is up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and this one is going to be
about uh youtube groups which are a a
kind of a new feature not all that new
on youtube but i'm going to show you
guys uh that anyway and yes your
wallpaper link will be in the
description guys anyway let's just go
ahead and scroll down uh you'll notice
if someone is running the youtube 2.0
layout which i am running right now on
my channel if you scroll down to the
bottom you'll be able to see
what group they are a member of and
right now i created an mkbhd
group on youtube and uh this is a group
i've created for people who are you know
starting out on youtube and uploading
their own videos and who actually want
more exposure and i'll i'll see the
videos that you guys post to this group
because i get emails and then i'll be
able to uh you know go ahead and uh rate
them comment and possibly check out your
channel and subscribe to you so if you
want to go ahead and join the group the
link is youtube.com
group slash mkbhd group and this is what
a group looks like and if you guys want
i'll do a video on an overview of you
know what a google group looks like
anyway uh everyone who's joining the
group right now i'm looking for
moderators and people to moderate the
topic so if i do know you or i like your
channel that i see you join my group
i'll go ahead and add you as a moderator
and hopefully i like the videos you post
too anyway i'll scroll back up to the
top here i'm going to show you guys how
to create your own youtube group should
you want to do that go ahead up to the
right hand side here i see that account
button click the account button
and scroll down and you'll actually see
this little groups button under more and
i'm going to go through a lot of these
kinds of things because there's some
interesting things in here that you guys
might actually might not actually notice
but go ahead and hit that groups button
and here are all the groups that i am a
member of
and here is the mkbhd group go ahead and
create a group right here so this is
groups you own
i own this one group right here and here
are all of the groups that i'm a member
of so go ahead and hit that create a
group button
and you can add a number of things such
as the group name mine was mkbhd uh some
tags to help people find um help help
people find your group as well as the
description and choose your own channel
name url or actually a group url and
it'll actually be youtube.com channel
slash and then a name
now i couldn't use mkbhd because i have
a uh i have another youtube channel as a
backup called youtube.com mkbhd so i
used uh youtube.com channel slash mkbhd
group and that's just what i did
obviously science in tech was the
category and you can choose a whole
bunch of settings before hitting that
create group button
and that is basically it so yeah when
you uh when you visit someone who's a
member of your group you will see at the
bottom of their channel
that that is what it looks like that is
the group that i've decided to display
on my channel that i'm a member of
so there are 104 members right now uh
quite a few people who are members are
posting videos and i'm looking for
moderators so if you guys just want to
go ahead and join up that group that
would be awesome and uh tell your
friends they probably want to join this
group too to get a little more exposure
anyway the latest video that you choose
to submit will be featured on the group
right here and uh or the the top rated
or the most recent depending on what you
select up here
and that is basically it so thanks for
watching guys i hope you uh you enjoy uh
the google the youtube group i keep
wanting to say google group
but i hope you guys enjoy the youtube
group that i have created you know feel
free to post some videos uh for me to
rate comment and look at your channel
thanks for watching guys peace